hello everyone I almost already recorded
this video but then my computer decided
to go into well my operating system
windows decided to go into an automatic
update and restarted my computer so that
was very unfortunate because I was very
happy with how the first recording was
going but you know be that as it may we
have a very nice game from round 8 of
the 2018 s grand chest or as your next
move
rapid tournament in Leuven it's a nice
game between Fabian of Khurana and Levon
Aronian so as you've seen in round seven
even four games out of five were
decisive games and out of those four
decisive games all four were one with
the black pieces so very interesting
turn of events as you know it really
this game will also be one of those
games that shows that sometimes it's
very nice to take a break from classical
time format as in classical time format
you know 95% of the game is basically
preparation and then if you make one
little mistake you're gonna suffer for
hours and hours on and then you're
either gonna miraculously save the game
or you know you lose the game
deservingly so this will be a very nice
game as Fabi did not have the greatest
tournament so far he faces Levin Aragon
who is currently second with Sergei
Carrick and trying to catch up to
Westley so who is in the lead and before
we check out to this very nice game we
do have a couple of photos for the photo
challenge
I still hope you're enjoying my previous
photo challenge definitely not an easy
one but for this one I decided you know
let make it not so difficult so here it
is best of luck to everyone and I really
hope all of you know who this person is
so here it is there we have it
I really hope like 99% of you who are
trying to solve this should know who
this person is and just for fun I
prepared one one more photo of this
person this this was taken in 1994 and
this next one was from 1998 and this
photo has a special guest in it and it's
a photo with a dolphin so here it is I
actually never saw this photo before so
I was very happy when I found it I hope
you know you're happy as well and we do
have
one photo from this encounter Caruana
versus our onion it was sent to me by a
subscriber via email and mr. morning
class so thank you mister marnik here it
is let's check it out so there we have
it
as usual the players are avoiding eye
contact as you know we don't want to
chitchat with your opponent before the
game or you know I make friends because
well you want to crush him unless you're
unless you make out a linear I'm gonna
stare at your opponent for the entire
game and before the game and probably
you know whenever you get the chance but
let's check out this game
so Bobby has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 so the
royal opus and now Knight to f6 we have
the Berlin defence d3 Bishop to c5 c3 d5
Knight B to d2 both players Castle D
captures on e4 d captures on e4 and a5
we have a 4 and Queen to e7 so a very
nice line of the Berlin defence were the
Queen's remain on the board which is
also something that's that's kind of
nice in in any format but in the
classical time format where you will a
lot of times you will see variations
that are not usually played in classical
time format or maybe even never played
in classical time format so H 3 9 3 a
tree maneuvering the Knight to d6 rook
to e1 and 9th to d6 Bishop to d3 Bishop
to e6 9th to F 1 we have f6 now
solidifying the e5 pawn Bishop to e3
Bishop captures and Knight captures and
Queen to f7 Queen to eat to further
controlling the C 4 square rook F to d8
and now rotate the D 1 and now Knight to
e7 this Knight is now gonna be riemann
over all the way to c4 so nice to e7
we have h4 9 e to c8 bishop to c2 and
night to b6 now the night is ready to
come to c6 and start a series of
exchanges nice to be too controlling c4
and now Knight it does come to c4 so 94
Knight captures on c4 Knight captures
and
the d5 bushel captures as that knight on
d5 is a monster pawn captures on d5 and
now Knight back to d6 and here Fabi goes
for c4 c4 is a very nice move preparing
c5 also it frees the third rank for the
rook to come into the game the row
politer support the c5 pawn by pushing
it to c5 or in some variations the roof
may even serve as you know an attacking
piece and go all the way to g3 so we
have b6 preventing c5 rook does come to
a three and now f5 rook the c3 preparing
to pull the pawn we have E 4 and now c5
pawn captures rook captures and now rook
to e8 rook the c1 now when the bishop
moves two rooks will be attacking the c7
pawn so you know preemptively in
defending the c7 point rope to e7 Bishop
to d1 we have F 4 and now Queen to e1
not allowing f3 to come with an attack
on the Queen Aragon does push f3 and
here we have rook one to c3 a very
important move if you try something like
g3 then you allow III let's rope the c3
was basically simply stopping this e3
push and now you can't really capture
and you know if you whatever you do
simply rook rook 5 to see 3 for example
attacking the pawn then e2 is coming and
after we move the bishop then it's
pretty it's a terrible position for
white rook to b8 is coming the Queen may
even find her way all over all the way
to h3 then g5 can be used to break open
the position I would be it will be a
losing position for white so after this
f3 rook want to see 3 def ever stopping
aragon from pushing e3 sorry about that
sir about that are in place after this
rook want the c3 he plays rook to f8 and
here we have Queen to f1
Queen to f1 is a well is basically a
losing move for white here it's it's
it's almost as Fabi forgot why he played
this move he played this move so he
could play g3 and g3 here would would
stop blacks attack because now III
doesn't really
do anything you can simply capture it
and after rook captures captured with
the Queen and black really has nothing
here
but after this rook to a fate Queen to
f1 such is the way of the rapid time
format and now our engine plays Queen to
g6 now Queen to g6 comes with the threat
of our the this Queen is now pretty much
stuck on f1 as she constantly has to
keep watch of the g2 pawn and another
thing is now III definitely will be an
idea here the the idea is if you play
something like rook captures on c7 then
you get rook captures rook captures and
III once again is possible because the
Queen is not on f1 and after something
like F captures you simply push pull the
pawn to f2 King moves and now after
Queen to b4 there's really nothing you
can do against Queen captures on h4 this
will be checkmate so after this Queen to
g6 move we have King to h2 trying to
prevent it this way
g3 here would also not work because now
you once again and get III and now after
something like Bishop to c2 attacking
the Queen now there is there's since you
played g3 you cannot capture here
because then Queen captures and g3 would
be possible
so now after Bishop c2 attacking the
Queen you get pawn captures with Czech
Queen captures and now Queen to g4
rook to e2 is a terrible threat but
there's really no way to stop it even if
you try something like Bishop to d3 to
prevent rookie - you're still gonna get
rookie - and after captures captures now
your queen is under attack from the rook
the point is already here protected by
the Queen and whatever you do for
example Queen e1 then rook the f1 check
is coming captures captures captures and
there's really nothing for you to do
here black is gonna get even more
material or even go for a checkmating
attack so a very unpleasant move Queen
to g6 and you know our it was like our
own and found this movie in a matter of
seconds
Fabi tries Queen King to h2 and now we
have Queen to g4 rook captures on c7 is
played but g3 I wouldn't g3 wouldn't be
any better here because once again you
get III
the queen is on f1 this III is
constantly a threat Rob captures rook
captures pawn captures and now Knight
comes to e4 you can't really defend
Queen characters and g3 you can try but
if you decide even this this doesn't
really work for white at all Queen
character skin captures and now Knight
captures on c5 we don't even have to
capture the rook you can simply push f2
but okay just capture the rook and you
are up a whole rook
so after Queen to g4 rook captures on c7
was an attempt by Fabi Queen captures on
h4 would check King to g1 and now rook
to e5 and here after this work to e5
move Fabi resigned the game and a very
nice victory 411 Aragon why did he
resign well there's really nothing to do
here the threat of course is rook h5
foul by Queen to h2 or h1 checkmate if
you capture here then you get to move g5
check the King has nowhere to go you
have to block with the Queen you lose
the Queen and the game and on the other
hand after rook to e5
you could try g3 but then Queen to h6
and there is no defense whatsoever
against a rogue h5 followed by a rogue
h1 checkmate and this looks kinda nice
so probably going to use this as a
thumbnail yeah definitely going to use
this as a thumbnail so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
we're gonna check out at least one more
game either from around 9:00 or if round
9 will be a boring round and perhaps one
more game from round 8 as from round 7
is run 7 was a really eventful round and
also round 8 was really great so yeah I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check through my previous videos here I
think for watching and I will see you
soon with what probably one more game
from round 9 of the 2018 Grantchester is
your next move
so thank you all and I will see you soon